this is the house in Beirut that Carlos
going is said to have fled to but
there's no sign of him here just lights
and the security guards outside saying
he's not at home many Lebanese view the
former Nisa and CEO as a successful
businessman and is a symbol of their
country's large diaspora but in Tokyo
the unexpected turn of events has
sparked outrage the kind of thing people
with power and money can get away with
I've seen a few media reports but there
are some things that Gaughan did that I
don't understand I think he fled because
he did something wrong but whoever
escapes wins you know I am many people
with money Goins escape to Lebanon is
the latest stunning twist in a roller
coaster journey that saw him fall from
boardroom to detention center here he
spent more than 100 days in Spartan
conditions far removed from his
sometimes extravagant lifestyle the
automotive tycoon stands accused of
underreporting his salary to the tune of
85 million dollars prosecutors also
allege he skimmed off millions of
dollars from the company for his
personal use Cohen has repeatedly denied
all accusations in a statement the 65
year old said the Japanese justice
system was quote rigged and that he
escaped injustice Japan does not have an
extradition treaty with Lebanon so it's
unclear what steps Tokyo might take next
so where could this be headed for more
Monica Jones with DW businesses here in
the studio Goins says he's being
persecuted by government officials is
there anything to back that up well you
know we've been covering this story of
course over the past 2 12 months but so
much else has have been happening so I
had to read up a bit to jog my memory
and it's true I mean the gun case
certainly has put Japan's judicial
system in particular the hostage system
into the limelight something that we
didn't really know much about beforehand
Japan
has an incredibly low crime rate and
perhaps it's not just because it's a
well-functioning society perhaps people
are simply too scared of being arrested
in the first place we remember that car
was gone was arrested in November 2018
and he faced a trial in April 2020
there's a long time and that has to do
with the Japanese system focusing on
interrogation with the aim of getting a
confession and prosecutors seem to be
although the hostage system they seem to
be able to keep people locked and take
as much time as they need I mean give
you an example for a minor crime like
shoplifting they can keep a shoplifter
of up to 23 days there's something
unthinkable here so when God says that
he's not less pled to justice but
injustice and probably just the length
of time he was kept under arrest before
facing trial maybe he has a point
okay well certainly there are
differences as you pointed out between
the Western and Japanese judicial
systems and certainly in terms of
pretrial detention um Monica how did he
escape certainly he wasn't being that
way isn't it I mean he was on bail and
that didn't include that he was allowed
to leave Japan his lawyer confirmed that
just a short while ago his lawyer also
says that he was completely taken by
surprise that he still has all three
passports he was born in Brazil Carlos
go and he has French and Lebanese
citizenship so how did is he escape I
mean everybody who was asked or asked to
comment on it has so far either declined
like a spokesman of Nissan said we don't
talk about this spokeswoman for the
Lebanese embassy Tokyo said we had no
idea what was happening and the French
junior tournament Minister has just come
out saying well hold on first of all
nobody is above the law but as a French
citizen he would be entitled to consular
support well we know he's left Japan on
a private plane via Turkey he's now in
Beirut and without an extradition treaty
as we heard Japan can do very little
about it right now
so where does this go from here
interesting interesting because go and
says
well first of all he was a giant and the
auto industry he he rescued Nitin from
the brink of bankruptcy masterminded the
alliance with Renault and after this
major blow where he's been faced now
with four charges that still in place
including for enriching himself through
payments to a dealership in the Middle
East and where is he now he's now in
Lebanon out of reach and he says he can
now finally commute freely with the
media and he's looking forward to doing
though starting next week so 2020 is
going to be well maybe we'll find out
more about the case and Bryan I can see
a big Hollywood movie in the making and
I certainly see some press conferences
next down the pipeline Monica thanks
very much